اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه للتحليل
العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه
كما العاده نستضيف هنا اللواء فائز الدوير
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي لقراءه ما
خلف هذه العمليات العسكريه الجاريه في
مجمل قطاع غزه وقبل ذلك ايضا يكون معنا
محمود الكن ليشرح لنا على الخارطه
التفاعليه كيف تتحرك هذه العمليات ا نعم
اياد ما نزال نشاهد العمليات العسكريه في
جنوب القطاع وشمال القطاع العمليات عسكريه
في جنوب القطاع اظهرت الاقمار الصناعيه في
ال من ديسمبر بان التوغل ما يزال محدودا
حتى ذلك الوقت على الاقل هنا في حاولت
القوات الاسرائيليه التوغل الى غرب بني
سهيلا وتقريبا الى شرق خان يونس التوغل
تقريبا كان يقدر بحوالي 500 متر الى كيل
متر واحد عن المناطق التي كانت تتمركز
فيها المدرعات اي انها انتقلت من هذه
النقطه وحتى هذه النقطه في حين تبقى
المنطقه الشماليه في خانيونس ما يزال
المحاور التوغل فيها من شارع كيسوفيم
باتجاه جنوبا صلاح الدين وقليلا الى الغرب
من محور صلاح الدين والمطاحن ومدينه حمد
في هذه النقطه هذا بالنسبه لخان يونس ما ت
ما تزال ايضا المعارك تجري هناك باستهداف
سواء بقذائف الهاون العبوات في هذه هي
مناطق الاشتباك لكن الابرز كان هنا في
شمال
القطاع دعونا نشاهد هنا محاور رئيسيه يتم
فيها التوغل والقصف وعمليات المقاومه
الكبيره هنا نتحدث عن الشيخ رضوان نتحدث
كذلك عن بالطبع جباليا جباليا كان المحور
الاشتباكات منذ اسبوعين على الاقل نتحدث
هنا عن محاولات قوات الاحتلال فصل المخيم
عن جباليا بالتقدم من هذين الم محورين
ربما يبرر هذا الاشتباكات الضاريه
والعنيفه في الشيخ رضوان كان هناك محاولات
الضغط من هذا الاتجاه من الغرب باتجاه
الشرق ومن هنا من الشمال ايضا باتجاه
الغرب في محاوله للتطويع
وايضا قصف شديد على جباليا جباليا البلد
جباليه النزله خلال الايام الماضيه
وبالتالي نشاهد هذا الضغط الكب على جباليه
لكن ايضا اذا ما شاهدنا هذه
الخريطه هناك ايضا اتجاه
ل الضغط
على التفاح حي التفاح هو هنا شمال
الشجاعيه بالتالي ربما يفسر ذلك
بانه اعاقه للقوات الاسرائيليه في التوغل
في هذا المحور ومحاوله فتح محور اخر او
مناوره اخرى لكن ما يدل على العمليات
عسكريه وبان هذه المناطق مناطق توغل
واشتباك وليست فقط مناطق سيطره او ما يسمى
بالعرف العسكري التطهير والتمشيط هو جحر
الديك هنا اذا ما اتجهنا الى جح جحر
الديك جحر الديك ما يزال منطقه لعمليات
المقاومه قالت فيها انها
استهدفت مجموعه من الياء الجنود
المتحصنين داخل ال الابنيه اضافه الى ذلك
باستخدام العبوات الناسفه وغيرها هنا تثار
تساؤلات عن كيفيه تعريف مناطق التمشيط او
التطهير او السيطره او التوغل حتى ضمن
العمليات التي تزداد ضراوه كلما اقتربنا
من المناطق السكنيه هنا وهذا ما سنناقشه
معكما مياده واللواء فايز بالنسبه لمعارك
اليوم التي تزداد ضروه في جباريا تحديدا
وجحر الديك سابدا من جحر ديك محمود
وتحديدا هنا اللواء فايز كان ملاحظا
عمليتان نوعيت اليوم اعلنت عنهما القسام
في جحر الديك الاولى كانت استهدفت كتيبه
راجله وا ايضا كان هناك ب طبعا عبوه مضاده
للافراد وكذلك بالت بي جي عبوه مضاده
للدروع كانت هناك استهداف اخر في جحر
الديك كيف ترى العمليات في جحر الديك في
هذه المرحله هي لازالت شوكه في خاصره
الاحتلال منذ اليوم الاول وصت قوات
الاحتلال ور على الرغم انها تعتبر من
منظور عسكري منطقه رخوه لانه لا يوجد فيها
موانع طبيعيه هي ارض زراعيه مساحتها 6 م م
تقريبا اي فرغم كل ذلك لكن ما قدمته جحر
الديك كان شيء يعني يفوق الخيال معظم
العمليات النوعيه والتي كانت نتائجها
مؤلمه لجيش الاحتلال من حيث اعداد القتلى
والجرحى معظمها جاء في جحر الديك معظم
العمليات التي تحمل سمه الابداع المطلق من
حيث الاستطلاع وتحضير مجموعه العمل
ومهاجمه الهدف لاحظنا عندما تم المهاجمه
وعرض الفيديو وتسلق السواتر اذا هذه تقدم
لنا عينه عن ان عن التحول في المرحله
الثالثه التي يتحدث عنها جيش الاحتلال
بانه بدا منذ مساء اول امس يتحدث عن مرحله
جديده انشاء مناطق عازله اعاده تموضع قوات
وتنفيذ عمليات حسب الضروره الى غير ذلك
اذا كانت جحر الديك لا يزال لا يستطيع
السيطره عليها في هذا اليوم كان هناك
غارات جويه في بيت في بيت حنون في اقصى
الشمال الشرقي لماذا تستخد يعني ضربات
جويه علما انه النشاط الجوي في هذا اليوم
دون المعدل العام ودون التوقع فاذا كانت
لا تزال الان تقصف في الطائرات في منطقه
بيت حنون عن اي سيطره يتحدث يضاف الى ذلك
الان تحدث عن الشيخ رضوان وعن جباليا
ومخيم جباليا وعن
التفاح هذه الفتره اشعر كان وحدات جيش
الاحتلال في حاله تضارب يبدو ان هناك عدم
وضوح في في الاهداف وظهرت اصوات
ويهود براك رئيس وزراء وزير دفاع سابق
رئيس اركان سابق
تحدث نائب وزير دفاع سابق تحدث عن ضبابيه
الاهداف وعن
وجود نعم ناب رئيس كانه يتحدث عن وجود
خلاف حتى داخل مجلس الحرب لانهم يطالبوا
نتنياهو ان يحدد الاهداف حتى يتمكنوا من
اداره المعركه وتحدث فعليا عن انعدام ثقه
بين المؤسسه السياسيه والعسكريه نعم
وبالتالي الان اذا لاحظنا وتسلسل في
الاحداث خلال 48 ساعه في الشيخ رضوان
لوحده كان هناك عمليه انسحاب ثم الان اعاد
العمليات الاشتباك كذلك في منطقه جباليا
مخيم جباليا ومحاوله الوصل بين مخيم
جباليا والفالو هذه تراجع الحديث عنها
لعده ايام ومن ثم عاد الحديث عنها الشيء
الملفت انه الان بدا الحديث لم تبدا
المعركه لكن بدا الحديث عن معركه حي
التفاح هذا يعني هذ هذه ك الخارطه امامنا
ماذا سيقدم لا اعتقد انه سيقدم الكثير
لانه هو فشل في فصل المخيم جباليه عن
جباليا فيحاول وفشل في الشجاعيه وانسحبت
الكتيبه 13 من الشجاعيه كانه يريد يعني
هناك حاله من التخبط في قراءه المعركه لدى
قاده جيش الاحتلال فبالتالي يحاول ان يبحث
عن منطقه قد تقدم له
خدمه تعبو وعمليات فيحاول ان يجرب حظه
لواء نحن لسنا امام تكتيك عسكري عندما
يعني لاحظنا حتى التفاح كان هناك في
الايام الاولى للحرب تواجد هناك ومحاولات
لبعض العمليات العسكريه ثم اختفى الحديث
عن التفاح يعود الان مره اخرى جباليا
الشيخ ايضا بيت حانون كما ذكرت قبل قليل
يعني ما الذي يجري الان في خلال اخر ثلاثه
ايام من المعركه منذ منذ الاصدار
التعليمات
بانسحاب الكتيبه 13 بدا يبدو هناك في
القاطع الشمالي على الاقل دعيني افصل بين
القاطع الجنوبي والقاطع الشمالي في القاطع
الشمالي بدا هنا هنا ك ارتباك لدى قوات
جيش الاحتلال لانها يبدو تضارب التعليمات
القادمه هكذا افسر تضارب التيمات القادمه
اليها من خلال القنوات العسكريه واعاده
تغيير هذه التعليمات والاوامر بناء على
اوامر القياده السياسيه وضعت هذه القوات
في حاله ارتباك ففي بعض الايام تنسحب في
اليوم الاخر تعاود تحاول ان تدخل ال
المنطقه وهذا الامر اعطى فرصه للقوات
المدافعه من الفصائل الفلسطينيه وهذا
انعكس في الارقام التي بدا يعلن عنها جيش
الاحتلال بالامس اعلن عن عدد من القتلى
وعن 42 جريح في هذا اليوم تحدث عن خ 24
ساعه 14 14 لكن الارقام التي جاءت من
القسام والفصائل 28 يعني هو تحدث عن 50%
وبالتالي بدانا نتفاءل انه سيفسح عن حقيقه
مكنون الخسائر لديه اذا هذه المنطقه تشهد
ارتباك في اداره المعركه من قبل قوات جيش
الاحتلال
والارتباك في جم في جمله واحده الارتباك
يعود لسببين براوه المقاومه وقدرتها على
منعه من تحقيق اي انجاز تكتيكي
والارتباك في اداره المعركه من قبل قاده
وضباط جيش الاحتلال هذه في المنطقه
الشماليه اقف معك فيما يتعلق بالارقام
عندما نتحدث عن 14 نحن امام نمط تراكمي
تصاعدي في عدد القتلى من الجنود والضباط
في وقت اننا لازلنا نتحدث عن زخم في القصف
الجوي والمدفعي ومفترض ما يتحدث عنه جيش
الاحتلال توسع في العمليات البريه يعني
الان هذا الرقم في ازياد لانه المعارك
ازداد الضراوه اولا وحاله الارتباك في جيش
الاحتلال ثانيا يعني هذا الرقم عندما الان
يصبح القائد الفرعي مستوى قائد كتيبه
وقائد سريه لا يعرف ماذا يعمل وينتظر
الاوامر يكون في حاله ارتقا ايه ارتباك
وبعد فتره تقارب شهرين من بدء المعركه بدا
الملل والتعب
والارهاق يلقي بظلاله على الجيش ولاحظنا
في احد الفيديوهات كيف مجرد ان توقفت
الدبابه هكذا اقرا في الفيلم خرجوا منها
وكانوا بجانبها يحتم وجاءتهم قذيفه قذيفه
مضاده للافراد اذا هذه هي الحاله العامه
هذه طائره الكبتر تنقل الجرحى وهذ يعني
يفترض ان تكون جراحهم خطره لانه يحتاجوا
الى انقا اني
وسريع كرام كان مواكبا طيل الساعات
الماضيه لهذه الطائرات وهي تنقل الجرحى
وكان قد رصد بالفعل كثافه لاستخدام
الطائرات المروحيه كما قلت يؤشر الى ان
الاصابات خطيره كلما شاهدنا قصف قنابل
استخدام القنابل الدخانيه علينا ان نتوقع
وحاولوا ان تربطوا الاحداث كلما شاهدنا
سواتر من الدخان بعدها في الساعات اللاحقه
او في اليوم التالي يتم الحديث عن اعداد
اكثر في القتلى لماذا لانه تكون القوات
المعاديه او قوات جيش الاحتلال دخلت في
كمين هناك معركه ضاريه هناك خسائر تبدا
الان بانشاء حاجز لتحديد الرؤيه على
المقاتلين ويبدا عمليات الاخلاء باستخدام
الطائرات العموديه طيب سنعود ونواصل ما
نقراه في هذه الصور ولكن نوو فقط بالاخبار
العاجله متحدث باسم الحوثيين يقول البارجه
اطلقت صواريخ نحو طائره استطلاع يمنيه
انفجر احدها قرب سفينه جابونيه بالبحر
الاحمر هذه في ضمن العواجل ضمن هذه
التغطيه
المستمره ايضا لربما لدينا المزيد بارجه
امريكيه فتحت النار على طائره استطلاع
تابعه للقوات البحريه اليمنيه في البحر
الاحمر ونذكر مشاهدينا ان الحوثيين يقومون
بعمليات النوعيه في باب المندب والبحر
الاحمر و ذلك بوقف اطلاق نار شامل في غزه
اذا مره اخرى المتحدث باسم الحوثيين يحيى
سريع يقول البارجه اطلقت صواريخ نحو طائره
استطلاع يمنيه انفجر احدها قرب سفينه
جابونيه بالبحر الاحمر ويؤكد جانب الحوثي
بانه يستهدف السفن التي لها ارتباط
باسرائيل تحديدا في نقل البضائع
اذا بارجه كما ذكرنا امريكيه فتحت النار
على طائره استطلاع تابعه للبحريه اليمنيه
بالبحر الاحمر وفق ما اعلنه
الحوثيون اذا ايضا اريد ان اعرج على جزئيه
ذكرتها في ضمن هذه القراءه لواء فايز
تتعلق بان الكثافه فيما يتعلق بالغارات
الجويه قلت قليلا وكان هناك تزامن
لتصريحات تقول ان الامر مرتبط بشكل او
باخر بالخوف من الخسائر في الجنود او
المحتجزين هذا ما يقوله هذا يعني الاهداف
استنفذت يعني حجم الدمار قد يرقى الى 80%
وبالتالي لم يعد هناك زخم او بنك اهداف
حقيقي الاهداف استهلكت وبالتالي لم يبقى
الا المدارس الاونر ومخيمات اللاجئين
ومناطق النزوح وبالتالي رغم اجرامه
واستهدافه للمدارس وللمستشفيات الان لم
يبقى لديه اي بنك اهداف حقيقي لهذا سبب
نجده في الفتره الاخيره على مدار عده ايام
دمر كافه الشريط ال بعمق 300 متر على طول
المنطقه الشرقيه ولكن هناك تصعيد وهناك
غارات سواء بالطائرات المسيره او
بالطائرات العموديه او بالطائرات المقاتله
في القاطع الجنوبي في منطقه شرق خان يونس
لا هناك لا تزال كثافه للغارات وان كانت
اقل من المستويات السابقه لانه طبيعه
المعارك في تلك المنطقه اوسع نطاقا من حيث
النطاق الجغرافي ومن حيث عدد القوات لهذا
السبب لاحظي انه الافلام القادمه من
القاطع الجنوبي اقل من الافلام القادمه من
المنطقه الشماليه بسبب ضراوه المعارك
وطبيعه الارض والمسافات البينيه ما بين
البيوت كانها تفرض تحديدات اضافيه على
مقاتلي القسام والجهاد الاسلامي بحيث ينفذ
العميه في كثير من الحالات ولا يستطيع
تصويرها لنوس نطاق التحليل العسكري معك
لواء فايز نستفيد من وجودك معنا لربط هذه
العواجل بهذا المشهد اذا كما ذكرنا انصار
الله الحوثيين هم يحاولون استهداف كل
السفن كما قالوا التي لها ارتباط باسرائيل
في محاوله لارسال رساله واضحه تتعلق
بضروره وقف اطلاق النار بشكل شامل في غزه
وانهاء هذه المعاناه حتى تامن هذه السفن
اليوم عندما نتحدث عن هذه الاخبار جديده
لربما هذه صور من البحر الاحمر اذا نتحدث
عن صاروخ اطلق من بارجه وفق روايه
الحوثيين وانه انفجر قرب سفينه جابونيه في
البحر الاحمر وهو ق كان قد اطلق لاست داف
طائره مسيره حوثيه كيف تقرا هذا المشهد
الان الحوثييين كما اشرتي ومنذ بدايه
الحرب وبداوا يتدخلوا ولكن بتصعيد مدروس
في البدايه كانت الاستهدافات ترسل باتجاه
فلسطين المحتله تقوم المدمرات الامريكيه
الفرنسيه في احد المرات يسقطوا معظم هذه
الطائرات لانه وقت وقت الاستهداف المقابل
واسع عندما تتحرك من اليمن الى ام رشراش
كماي الاسم القديم لايلات ف فتره احتماليه
اعتراضها تبقى طويله زمنيا ثم تحولوا
لعمليه فرض الحصار البحري على الكيان
الاسرائيلي وبدوا بعمليات الاستهداف اما
بالصواريخ واما بالطائرات المسيره
والاستهداف هي تاخذ في الواقع الجغرافي
تقريبا من ميناء المخا شمالا الى ما شمال
ميناء الحديده باكثر من 120 م هذه هي
المسافه لانه هذا هو تواجد الحوثي الحوثي
لا يتواجد في باب المندب باب المندب يعتبر
تابع الى الحكومه اليمنيه جزيره مون تابعه
لهم ويوجد فيها قوات اماراتيه تابعه
للجنوب باعتبار و انما هم اخر تواجد لهم
في من ميناء المخا شمالا وبالتالي هي
المنطقه هي بعد تقريبا بعد 40 م من مضيق
باب المندب مسافه المخا المخا عن باب
المندب حوالي 55 م وبالتالي هذه المنطقه
تعتبر تحت سيطر الحوثيه وهي منطقه صعبه
المسالك نعم توجد فيها سهل ما بين البحر
والجبل قد في بعض يرقى الى 12 م و1 م لكن
بعدين بعديها مناطق جبليه صعبه جدا تسمح
بالاختفاء
وتقدم الستر والتخفف للقواعد الصاروخيه
وبالتالي سيواجه التحالف معضله صعبه جدا
في التعامل مع الحوثيين نذكر هنا بالاسطول
المتواجد في البحر الاحمر و ابرز حاملات
الطائرات والسفن التابعه والمرافق لها
والتي تتواجد بشكل دائم هناك ووتي
يستهدفها ايضا الحوثيون عبر اما الصواريخ
البالستيه او الطائرات المسيره الان اي
هناك تشكيل تحالف صدرت بعض ال كثبت بعض
المواقع خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه بان بعض
الدول انسحبت وضربوا مثال ايطاليا وغيرها
من الدول اعلنوا انسحابهم لانهم لا يرغبوا
بالتورط لانه المستنقع اليمني او الرمال
اليمنيه عميق
اذا غاوا فيها لن يخرجوا الدول العربيه
لكل دوله خصوصيتها ولا تستطيع اي دوله ان
تشارك باستثناء دوله البحرين شاركت وهذا
ما اعلن الان ما هو حجم الماركه دور
المشاركه لن ادخل بهذه التفاصيل لكن دعيني
اقول انه العماد الرئيسي هي
البحريه الامريكيه البريطانيه الفرنسيه
وهي التي تحاول ان تقدم الحمايه لكنها هي
في دور الدفاع حتى هذه اللحظه القرار من
البيت الابيض لم يتخذ بعد وكتب عن ذلك في
هذا اليوم بانه حتى هذه اللحظه لا لا
يرغبوا بتوجيه ضربات الى الحوثيين في
الداخل اليمني لجمله اسباب احد هذه
الاسباب خوفا من عوده الحوثيين باستهداف
المملكه العربيه
السعوديه كسع نطاق لتوسيع نطاق العمل اذا
هذه تقوم بدور الدفاع فقط تعتر تض
الصواريخ تعترض الطائرات ولكن هذا لن يمنع
الحوثي من الاستمرار في الاستهداف اذا مره
اخرى او بذكر التحالف الذي اعلن عنه اوستن
قبل ايام مدى نجاعته في التعامل وحمايه
كما قال وقتها هذه الممرات المائيه بالنظر
للواقع الميدان التي الذي تراه انا لا
اعتقد انهم يستطيعوا ان يقدموا الكثير الا
اذا ارادوا توسيع دائره الصراع والبدء في
في استهداف الحوثيين الى غير ذلك ولكن اشك
في هذا التحول واذا جرى هذا التحول سيكون
تحول انتقائي جراحي يعني اذا تم كشف قاعده
صواريخ يمكن استهدافها اكثر من ذلك لا
يمكن ا الحديث عن دخول بري هذا امر يستحيل
وخارج اطار التفكير وحتى ال توسيع دائره
الاستهداف للحوثيين هناك معادله حساسه في
اليمن هناك معادله حساسه لا يمكن الاخلال
التوازن القائم اي لانه سيفتح المنطقه على
باب جهنم كان ايضا لافتا ان صواريخ
وطائرات الحوثيين اصابت اهدافا في كثير من
هذه الاستهدافات ولم تتمكن انظمه هذه هذا
الاسطول المتواجد في البحر الاحمر من
اعتراضها اليوم نتحدث عن اعتراض هذا
الصاروخ وانها حتى سقطت بالقرب من سفينه
اخرى جابونيه ولكن كيف نفسر ان هذه
الصواريخ والطائرات المسيره تصيب اهدافا
في كثير من الاحيان يعني اول استخدام
الصواريخ اللي تم استخدامها حتى اللحظه
اللي اتحدث بها احتماليه الاصابه محدوده
لماذا لانها صواريخ بالستيه وليست
الصواريخ بر بحر هناك نتحدث عن صواريخ
مجنحه صواريخ كروس تسير بخط مباشر
باستهداف مباشر ويكون تاثيرها فاعل ويمكن
ان يؤدي بالنسبه لسفن الشحن الى عمليه
الاغراق وال كاني اقول اليمن لا اتحدث
بلسانه كاني ارى انه يفكر هو يريد منع
عبور هذه هذه السفن سفن الشحن وليس الحاق
الضرري بها لكن في بعض الحالات قد يصيبها
الصاروخ وياتي لانه قوسي ياتي في سطح او
في احد في الجانب الايمن منها لانها متجهه
الى الشمال الغربي اذا
هو يهدف الى منع الملاحه ذات العلاقه
بالكيان الاسرائيلي ويتحدث يحيى سريع
وغيره بان السفن الاخرى التي ليس لها
علاقه غير لا تستهدف بالامس كان هناك
استهداف على بعد تقريبا 180 ميل ميل بحري
غرب شواطئ الهند الغربيه ل
ل لسفينه واتهمت ايران بانها اطلقتها من
داخل العمق الايراني من مناطق الجنوبيه
الشرقيه من ايران دعيني اقول الحوثي ربط
حريه الملاحه للكيان الاسرائيلي بدخول
المساعدات ورفع الحصاري عن قطاع غزه وهو
لا يزال يمارس هذه هذه المقاربه الان رد
الفعل لن يكون ناجعا في منعه الا بتوسيع
دائره الصراع وهذا ما لا ترغبه امريكا
وتحاول ان تتجنبه طيب المدى الذي يمكن ان
تصل اليه اسلحه الحوثي سواء كانت صواريخ
بالستيه او طائرات مسيره لنضعها على
الخارطه الان هذا نعود الى استهدافات
القديمه كانت تستهدف الرياض قاعده الملك
خالد استهدفت المصافي يعني كانت بعض
الحالات تصل الى 1800 متر الطائرات وبعض
الصواريخ اطلقت باتجاه اي فلسطين المحتله
اذا لديهم القدره الفعليه من حيث الصواريخ
البالستيه والطائرات المسيره ان يستهدفوا
اي هدف في مياه البحر الاحمر الان ناتي
الى النقطه الاخرى استخدام الصواريخ
المجنحه لديهم صواريخ اي يطلق عليها اسم
ميون مداها 80 م وبالتالي هذا بدات تستخدم
كتوجيه مباشر من الجغرافيا اليمنيه الى
السفن عندما تكون موازيه الى المنطقه التي
توجد فيها الصواريخ لانه كل لانه هذه
السفن
ستلج للعلم عرض الممر باب المندب داخل شرق
جزيره ميون 4 م م غير صالح للملاحه غربها
ما بين جزيره مون وجيبوتي 17 م بعد ذلك
يبدا البحر بالاتساع وبالتالي في بعض
الحالات قد تلجا السفن الى المسير على ما
يقرب من الشاطئ الغربي هنا في بعض الحالات
قد تخرج عن نطاق صواريخ ميون
اليمنيه طيب كنت قد اشرت في سؤال معك لواء
فايز على
اعتراض السفن الامريكيه لهذه الصواريخ
والطائرات المسيره هل انظمه الرادار لها
علاقه هنا بعدم اعتراض صواريخ في حالات
سابقه حدثت لا هو
يحاولوا ان يستهدفوا اي صاروخ قادم يعني
لكن هناك عندهم طبقات للرادارات وطبقات
لاسلحه الدفاع الجوي المتواجده على
المدمرات وبالتالي يتم استخدامها بناء على
نوع الهدف وزاويه اقتراب الهدف وارتفاع
الصاروخ اذا هذا يقرره القائم على العمل
داخله لكن كل مدمره لديها انظمه دفاع جوي
متعدده الطبقات لكن ليس بالضروره ان ان
تنجح في اسقاط كل الاهداف قد تسقط تس من
طائرات مسيره وتسل الطائره رقم 10 لانه
احتماليه الخطا موجوده هم يتحدثوا عن اسقا
امكانيه اقول امكانيه اسقاط كل الاهداف
الجويه ونجحوا في ذلك مرات عديده لكن يمكن
ان تنجح بعض الطائرات الان السؤال الثاني
اين هي هذه المدمرات والقطع البحريه هل هي
ضمن مدى الرادار لانه مدى الرادار يختلف
في بعضها يصل الى 150 م بعضها الى 200 م
وحسب منظومه الرادار نفسها فالان قد يكون
الحوثي لديه دراسه وتحديد قدرات وهذا امر
يجب ان يكون وبالتالي قد لا يستهدف بعض
السفن الشحن ما دامت ضمن اطار
حمايه المدمرات لاحظ الان ما انت اشرتي
اطلقوا صاروخ ل الاعتراف سقط بجانب سفينه
جابونيه اذا هذا يعطيني دلاله ان نقطه
الاطلاق كانت على وشك نهايه المدى
الراداري لمنظومه الرادار على تلك المدمره
ساعود الى جزئيه في هذا الاطار ولكن انضم
الينا الان محمد الاعطاب مراسل الجزيره من
صنعاء لربما يفيدنا بمزيد من المعلومات
محمد حول هذه الاخبار العاجله التي نريدها
ضمن هذه التغطيه
محمد نعم ما يخص حدث اشتباكات او اسقاط
مسيرات
جماعين الان ليس هناك بان رسمي لكننا ب
خلار
انجي الرسمي
العسكري يتحدث عن هذه والتي
تع اعتذر منك محمد اعتذر منك محمد الصوت
غير واضح لم نستطع فهم ما تقوله بالتالي
سنحاول معاوض الاتصال بك لمعرفه تفاصيل ما
جرى عود اليك وفايز في بعض حالات اخرى كان
هناك استهدافات من الحوثي لسفن تابعه
للاسطول او البوارج تم استهداف مدمره في
احد المرات السابقه ص ما الذي يفسر ذلك
كيف استطاع او كيف عجزت لنقل انظمه
الرادار من التعامل مع هذا الادا هناك
هناك هناك يعني الاما الامن المطلق غير
موجود الم يتم استهداف في تسعه اي في 11
سبتمبر اي برج التجاره الم يتم استهداف
البنتاجون في احد الطائرات وهي طائره
تجاريه
اذا البنتاجون هو مركز رمز القوه للجيش
الامريكي تم استهدافه الم تنزل طائره
طائره شراعيه في ساحه
الكرملين اذا ام مفهوم الامن المطلق في
قاموس الحمقى لا يمكن تح رغم امتلاك
البحريه الامريكيه منظومه ايجس المض
احتماليه حدوث خطا ما سواء خطا بشري او
خطا تقني انت تقودين الى مفارقه عجيبه
بيرل هاربر اها
مجزره البحريه
الامريكيه عندما تم التحقيق كان خطا بشري
خطا بشري لم يمرر المعلومه في وقتها ادت
الى تدمير الاسطول الامريكي في بيرل هاربر
اذا الخطا موجود سواء كان خطا بشري او خطا
تقني والان
كلما كان هناك زياده في الاعتماد على
التقنيه كل ما زالت احتماليه الخطا يعني
خطا بشري مفهوم نوعا ما خطا تقني ما الذي
تعنيه الخطا التقني تعطل احد
ال الاجهز التقنيه المرتبطه بشبكه الرادار
المرتبطه بشبكه الانذار مثال واضح جدا 7
اكتوبر طوفان الاقصى تم اطلاق 3200 صاروخ
في اللحظه الاولى ماذا كان تاثيرها تم
تعطيل منظومه الانذار الرئيسيه داخل
الكيان الاسرائيلي وبالتالي تزامنت مع مع
افعال
اخرى تدمير الابراج تدمير الرشاشات التي
تعمل اوتو وبالتالي دخل المقاتلين من
الانفاق وعلى السايكل وعلى الدراجه وعبر
السياج بعد ان تم تعطيل الحاجز الجدار
الموجود 30 متر تحت الارض عليه اجهزه
استشعار
وعليه كاميرات تم تعطيلها كلها وبالتالي
كان يعني التكنولوجيا المتطوره التي غالت
اي العقيده القتاليه الاسرائيليه في
الاعتماد عليها هي التي سهلت مهمه نخبه
القسام ودخول 1200 مقاتل كلما زاد
الاعتماد على التقنيه كلما زادت احتماليه
حدوث الخطا نع نعم هي تسهل العمل وتسبب
نجاح نجاحات كبيره جدا لكنها لا تنفي
الخطا لهذا السبب قد يحدث خطا وهنا وهذا
يعيدني الى سؤالك انه تم استهداف احد
المدمرات طيب من الناحيه الاستراتيجيه
اعتماد الحوثيين الان هذا الاسلوب من
الاستهداف بالطائرات او بالصواريخ وكما
ذكرت لسفن بعينها ليست كل السفن ك وكان
هناك تصريح واضح بهذا الشان هدفه ليس
اصابات مباشره وانما ترهيب انا اقول في
بعد تحليلي الحوثي لا يرض
في اصابه سفينه اصابه مباشره تؤدي الى
اغراقها هنا سيعطي
المبرر المطلق للاخرين ان يتدخلوا لكن هو
يطالب
بمنع الملاحه اذا سامن معها تدريجيا
وصعودا ولكن بتصاعد منضبط اذا كان هنا
كثير من الشركات بي بي وغيرها اتجهوا
باتجاه را راس الرجاء الصالح التامين
ارتفع
500% الاسعار
400% وبالتالي التاخير ثمانيه اسابيع كل
هذا بسبب اجراءات الحوثي لو سارع الى
اغراق احد سفن الشحن قد يكون رده الفعل
اسرع لا قليل دائم خير من كثير منقطع انا
سامنحك بادوات بسيطه دون ان اتورط في امر
كبير هكذا ا ليس عنصر المخاطره كبير هنا
في نها نهايه الامر هذا استهداف لمنطقه
تتواجد فيها يتواجد فيها اسطول كبير
وتتواجد فيها قطعات بحريه ومدمرات
وبالتالي هي منطقه ايضا استراتيجيه
بالنسبه ل لا تحد حتى هذه اللحظه لا يوجد
اعتراف بالحوثي انه يملك السياده الشرعيه
في اليمن الا من قبل ايران وحزب الله بقيه
الدول تعتبر الشرعيه الحكومه اليمنيه
المتواجده في الرياض اذا ندخل الان في حرب
غير نظاميه ليس بين دول دوله وتحالف نتحدث
بين
جماعه مسلحه تقاتل ضد ضد جيوش منظمه اذا
دخلنا في مصطلح الحرب اللام متناظره او
الحرب غير المتناظره وهنا هنا مكمل
الخطوره على التحالف بالتالي هو لا يواجه
جيشا نظاميا في معركه تقليديه يلحق بها
الهزيمه خلال 24 ساعه هو يتعامل مع منطقه
جغرافيه صعبه جدا مع اشخاص
يعرفوها معرفه دقيقه جدا لديهم الادوات
ولديهم القدره والذكاء على توظيف هذه
القدرات بالطريقه التي يروها مناسبه اشكرك
جزيل الشكر لواء فايز دويري بدانا من نقطه
وانتهينا في نقطه اخرى هكذا هو حال
التغطيات في الجزيره نشكرك جزير الشكر
ولقائنا بالتاكيد متابعه وصله الان نعود
بكم الى غرفه الاخبار ومتابعه هذه التغطيه
مع الزميل حسن جمول